В класі вчителя Крістіана Шмідта панують тиша та порядок.
Мобільні телефони тут заборонені.
Під час уроку їх слід вимкнути та забрати зі столу.
І все ж повністю відмовитись від них складно.
Таке відчуття, що чогось не вистачає.
Хочеться буть в курсі. Якщо інші вже щось знають,
тобі також потрібно це знати, щоб розуміти, що й до чого.
У цій гімназії в місті Трір на заході Німеччини мобільні телефони взагалі-то забороненi.
Але на практиці суворе табу діє тільки на час екзаменів,
адже списувати і підглядати - неприпустимо.
Спокуса спробувати завжди є, але зрештою ти не наважуєшся. Сміливості не вистачає.
Тим же, кому сміливості вистачило і кого спіймали на гарячому, загрожує єдина санкція - погані оцінки.
Директор школи намагається обмежити використання смартфонів  -
і більшість батьків його підтримують.
Заборона мобільних телефонів вкрай позитивно впливає як на концентрацію й увагу школярів,
так і на їхнє спілкування між собою.
При цьому вчителі в принципі не проти мобільних -
вони підтримують розумне використання смартфонів.
Мій досвід показує, що чим більше смартфони використовуються з навчальними цілями,
тим менше трапляється конфліктних ситуацій зі школярами через заборону.
Вчитель Крістіан Шмідт дозволяє своїм учням використовувати смартфони для навчання.
Наприклад, для пошуку інформації в інтернеті.
Це абсолютно нормально. І тоді школярі не відчувають себе обділеними.
Діти також підтримують такий компроміс.
Дорослі повинні зрозуміти, що сьогодні без техніки та без інтернету – нікуди.
І що школярам потрібні смартфони.
Як би не було, в цій трірській гімназії безлімітно користуватися інтернетом
дозволяють тільки старшокласникам
і лише в спеціально призначеному приміщенні - шкільному підвалі.